you're one of the most successful people
ever
you've built an incredible company
that has
a lot of impact what advice do you have
for young people
today
how to live a life they can be proud of
how to how to build something that can
um have a big positive impact on the
world
well
let's break that down because i think
you
proud of have a big positive impact well
you're actually listening and how to
live your life
are actually three different things that
um that i think
i mean they could line up but um
and also like what age of people are you
talking to because i mean i i can like
high school and college so you don't
really know what you're doing but you
dream big
and you really have a chance to to do
something unprecedented yeah
so
for people my age okay so let's maybe
maybe start with the the kind of most
philosophical and abstract version of
this yes every night when i put my
daughters
to bed
we go through this thing and like
they call it the good night things
because we're we're basically
what we talk about at night um and
and i i just i i
go through with them sounds like a good
show
yeah the good night things yeah
priscilla's always asking she's like can
i get good night things like i don't
know you go to bed too early um but it's
um
it's
but i basically go through with max and
and auggie um
you know what are the the things that
are most important in life right that i
just it's like what do i want them to
remember and just have like really
ingrained in them as they grow up and
it's
health
right making sure that you take care of
of yourself and keep yourself in good
shape
loving friends and family right because
you know having the the relationships
the the family and making time for
for for friends i think is
is um
perhaps one of the most important things
um and then the third is maybe a little
more amorphous but it is
something that you're excited about for
the future and when i'm talking to a
four-year-old often i'll ask her what
she's excited about for tomorrow or the
week ahead but i think for
for most people it's really hard
i mean the world is a heavy place and i
think like the the way that we navigate
it is that we have things that we're
looking forward to so whether it is
building ar glasses for the future or
um being able to celebrate my 10-year
wedding anniversary with with my wife
that's coming up it's like i think
people
you know you have things that you're
looking forward to um or for the girls
it's often i want to see mom in the
morning right it's like just but it's
like that's a really critical thing and
then the last thing is i ask them every
day
what did you do today to help someone
um
because i just think that that's that's
a really critical thing is like
like it's it's easy to kind of get
caught up in yourself and
um and and kind of stuff that's really
far down the road but
like did you do something just concrete
today to help someone and you know it
can just be as simple as okay yeah um i
helped set the table for lunch right or
you know this other kid in our school
was having a hard time with something
and i like helped explain it to him but
um but those are that's sort of like
if you were to boil down my overall life
philosophy into what i try to impart to
my my kids
those are the things that i think are
really important so okay so let's say
college so if you're graduating college
probably more practical advice
so i'm always very focused on people and
i think the most important decision
you're probably gonna make if you're in
college
is who you surround yourself with
because you become like the people you
surround yourself with
and
i i sort of have
this hiring heuristic at meta
which is that i will only hire someone
to work for me
if
i could see myself working for them not
necessarily that i want them to run the
company because i like my job but like
but but in an alternate universe if it
was their company and i was looking to
to go work somewhere um would i be happy
to work for them and i think that
that's a helpful heuristic
to help balance
when you're building something like this
there's a lot of pressure
to you know you want to build out your
teams because there's a lot of stuff
that you need to get done and you know
everyone always says don't compromise on
quality but there's this question of
okay how do you know that someone is
good enough and i think my answer is
i would want someone to be to be on my
team if i would work for them but i
think it's actually a pretty similar
answer
to like
if you were gonna go if you were
choosing friends or a partner or
something like that so when you're kind
of in college trying to figure out what
your circle is going to be trying to
figure out you know you're evaluating
different job opportunities
who are the people even if they're going
to be peers in what you're doing who are
the people who in an alternate
university you would want to work for
them because you think you're going to
learn a lot from them because they know
because they they are kind of values
aligned on the things that you care
about and they're going to like um and
they're going to push you but also they
know different things and have different
experiences that that are kind of more
of what you want to become like over
time so i don't know i think probably
people are too
in general objective focused and maybe
not focused enough on
the connections and
the people who they're who they're
basically building relationships with i
don't know what it says about me but my
place in austin now has um
seven legged robots so i'm surrounding
myself by robots which
is probably something i should look into
you